[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN WICKE: We're
presenting this paper at KDD
to share some of the lessons
we've learned designing
the TensorFlow's APIs.
We want to make machine
learning as easy as possible.
That's all of machine learning,
including deep learning,
including distributed
learning, including
learning in huge data sets.
The biggest challenge
to machine learning
is that it's such a
quickly evolving field.
If you're not careful,
APIs and frameworks
can become outdated
very quickly.
New developments can make
established methods obsolete
basically overnight.
Flexibility is therefore
a primary concern.
APIs must allow custom
behavior and anticipate
developments and research
results that haven't even
happened yet.
TensorFlow's main strengths
are that it's very flexible
and that it scales to
distributed settings.
We want to present an API that
preserves this flexibility
while making the
most common usage
patterns as simple as possible.
Distributed machine learning
gets very complex very quickly.
And we believe that we have
created a very simple way
to get started, and then scale
up to any problem size or model
complexity.
Designing APIs means
that you're making
a series of design decisions.
And those represent
fundamental trade-offs.
We have created tooling that
implements best practices.
This means that following
best practices is very easy.
While on the other
hand, if you want
to do something very unusual,
you won't get as much help.
That's why we have designed
the APIs in layers.
Generally the highest level
API will get you there fastest.
But if you need
something specialized,
you can escape to the
layer below or below.
The challenge for us was to
make sure that you can implement
some custom behavior in
one part of your code,
say, the [INAUDIBLE]
processing pipeline,
while reusing all of the
library implementations for all
the other parts of the code.
Everything described
in the paper
is now part of the
regular TensorFlow API.
You can look at the
estimators and [INAUDIBLE]
packages for the interfaces
that we describe in the paper.
They are available
as of TensorFlow 1.2.
If you're interested in learning
more, please do read our paper.
If you're new to
machine learning,
you can check out a talk
about effective TensorFlow
for non-experts that
I gave at Google IO.
[MUSIC PLAYING]